hi Brian I wanted to ask you a question
about what keeps me motivated so be
interesting and unique thing about
dealing with extreme environments where
people's lives are on the line is that
the environment itself is actually
inherently or revealing so you don't
have to worry about keeping a team
motivated because they're going to be
motivated by the fact that their life is
on the line or their health may be at
risk so instead of worrying about
motivation in these environments really
what you have to think about is how to
deal with those environments as they're
always changing and you have to
basically be able to lead based on
whatever situation and is going on at
the time and rather than reading
according to a particular and thank you
for now because whatever plan you came
up with yesterday or today is going to
be completely outdated tomorrow so
basically the idea of planning less and
executing more is what's going to keep a
team going in these types of Michael's
because you actually don't have to worry
about motivation in extreme environments